all right this week on true news we have
a new sponsor Brian Oh a brand new
sponsor hey I love a new sponsor I love
old sponsors as well but I love new
sponsors and the best part is we'd have
to talk about it because they sent us a
video that we can just show the whole
song [__] honestly makes my life easier
yeah roll the clip
introducing a revolution in gaming over
six months by APM is over 520 my kitty
has done in the game did you honestly
think we were gonna do anything but read
don't be stupid it's been about two
weeks since April Fool's but we still
got you guys you thought we weren't
raising you we're raising you all day
you just got raid rolled so obviously
this episode is sponsored by raid Shadow
legends genuinely this game has brought
me so many hours upon hours of quality
and attainment so realistically if
you're bored in lockdown then we have
the perfect solution for you for those
who don't know what Rachel Legends is
raid is a dark fantasy RPG which is on
mobile PC and it's also cross device
that means it can be on here or on your
laptop anywhere and the best part is
it's free to play most things on free
anymore no hedonism free no I can't
leave that yeah exactly
Oh radius so my favorite thing about Ray
eachother legends is when you're playing
it it doesn't feel like you're playing a
mobile game alright Brian let me show
you some gameplay so here is sort of the
main lobby area let's go to a battle all
right so we have sniper and gallic as
our champions in this one they've never
let me down before alright so down here
you've got your special moves let's go
for this easy ray Navarro's see how much
damage that caused them he's had enough
I'm not the steel crusher Oh No I've
lost sniper it's all it's a garlic
garlic don't let me down we're gonna go
for a cross flush and there we go he's
done so these are my champions at the
moment I've only got four I've got
garlic sniper chemist and axe man now
axe mine doesn't look as cool as the
rest but trust me he's powerful the
details just insane the hair the tattoos
everything it's like you're in that
world isn't it you just find yourself
sort of getting a loss you see that
character and you're just like he's a
real person and I've just gotta say a
big thank you to everyone who was
already downloaded the skin using our
link but obviously it's still more of
you out there yeah I wasn't read help us
support the show we tell you about red
you download red
simple and for those of you who have not
yet downloaded the game than you're in
luck as for new players the daily login
rewards have doubled from 90 days to 180
days each day you can claim your free
rewards from energy refills Silver's
gems to short and a free barbarian
legendary champion sill of the drakes
either just the way I said that sill of
the drinks so what are you waiting for
go to the video description and if
you're a new player you will receive one
hundred thousand silver one free energy
refill 50 gems and one free champion
this brain is executioner executioner he
is a beast does what you want mm-hmm I
like the style and you'll find your
extra rewards here in your inbox for the
next 30 days only so hurry up
so dogs are going to read for sponsoring
yet another true news at the sword
Thomas Lee you lot for support them also
if you haven't done yet or download that
game the legs of the description below
but for now it's time for some true news
[Music]
ah got a bit of a throat thing going on
at all it's not that it's not the thing
you know it's just a cold
yeah he seems coffin in there ah coffin
and what hug block knows partly you
don't know coffins are great sign though
is it yeah if I already hardcore vid
month and everyone knows you can't get
it twice no one's like that a triggered
you so basically you say it were true
Jordi tell us how how youtubers are
coping in lockdown
getting arrested chugging around for
having arguments for the day in the
office for us I mean YouTube is he used
to going viral let's see which one of
the nominees has [__] our life up the
worst I was up the girl yeah oh really
to toll do tell all stop does your
current last know about your girl who
look like her yeah was there an overlap
were you a good boy I was a good boy
faithful very faithful that's annoying
that cuz a true man lines one up for you
jump ship
really there's a first lesson I say you
get ill he's only young I've got to
teach you all you lads out there Lyman
or before you jump you never want to be
on your own I don't want to make myself
a son we'll shoot let's see what she's
been doing hey what's up guys it's
scarce you know we have a huge update of
the Muppet Show here what's up guys it's
Kara see ya you really does listen to
this to the Fitz Catarina and course and
situation the sad thing is whenever I
say this kid lovely guy all I can think
about is another Facebook Reno by rocky
rocky can we insert
this kid has got the heart of a lion
yeah he took a beating most people can
tell him he can chop [__] cuz they can
back it up I mean I wouldn't back it up
with his face so we don't know what
happened of course is a very big
youtuber and a lot of people know that
Carson has been dating at this other
streamer known as kateri know massively
puncheon I'm sorry yeah only on Twitch
kotappa only on twitch I should go to
twitch amazing yeah well just came out
recently that Carson's girlfriend
Katarina actually cheated on Carson with
his own friend Fitz put gin again oh
they're all of it this girl has a low
standards you know her you've got a
chance space yeah there must be
something more to it though I mean he's
probably a bad gamer or something yeah
that might obtain quality stream I don't
know if you're a twitch streamer and you
start going on killstreaks for days yeah
she's like no he could shoot look at the
size of his donations the rumors have
actually been servicing the catering
will also cheat on Carson with her
manager as well Oh tada Josie other so
as well as his best friend so his best
friend and his manager has he got a
brother go for the hat trick and
Katarina came out today and she actually
updated us to the dislike ratio on that
video what was a dislike it was like 4.4
k likes 21,000 dislikes let me see what
it suck no battery no it sounds like
something that flan doesn't say finally
how Nemorino 8.3 thousand likes now and
a hundred and seventeen thousand
dislikes let's see what she's got to say
for us self three men this is just what
we know about there's probably more
that's the mouth too many the fact that
Kieran was with five different dudes and
it seems like all these five guys were
in the public eye in some way
relationship with Carson was very
complicated
no [__] if you cheat on a woman it's the
end of the world
yeah they cheat on you it's complicated
it's complicated complicated yeah you
saw we were in a relationship I was just
doing what the [__] I want you're now
seeing a therapist and although I didn't
realize it at the time I was dealing a
lot with depersonalization they've an
awkward scapegoat there I'm sorry
[__] [__] you don't just go oh
I'm seeing a therapist now so you've
gotta forgive us you were [__] three
men at one goal and it was a blame and
on depersonalization I didn't know what
I wanted you want the dick that's quite
clear so the Google definition of
depersonalization is depersonalization
can consist of a detachment within the
south regarding one's mind or body
or being a detached observer of oneself
all right so it means you're doing stuff
but you're not responsible I like that I
like that so from that one whatever our
[__] up you confi personalization I'm
just gonna play that card
yeah and we're just gonna run with that
I don't want to come down too hard on a
young girl who's made a [__] mistake
right and I know I might have come
across a bit like that because I don't
feel like she's owning it I think she's
trying new but she's just failing she's
halfway there you're on camera you're
saying I've hurt people but you're not
committing there's no emotion there
that's the thing with me I can't see any
emotion behind the eyes I'd rather she
pretended to give a [__] I'd be upset
that just reads like this imagine you're
watching this and you're the boyfriend
in the future I want to be better I want
to focus on myself I think you focused
on yourself a lot no think about this
for a change a so how did her own
manager not know about Carson it looks a
bit like Luka Magnotta if he didn't kill
journaling he's Luke I'm not as nice
twin brother yeah Horsham was the guy
who literally got her tons of flowers
over twitch he was like one of the
biggest public relationships in her life
she used him for the [__] view she
seems to be a lot of those nowadays if a
girl like that comes your way and you
look like this kid I've always liked
funky like chuggers and get the Saabs
affair all right I'll take now everyone
feels sorry for him so he still wins and
now some girls gonna be out there oh hey
[__] check those two hams son he too
real was playing all sides of the coin
here she was literally leading Carson on
making him think that they were in a
relationship kind of like what an evil
called [__] as though really it's kind
of hot you incident I'll just see you
another right manipulating this [__]
clown god bless you son but you've been
played we've all had it I'll be in there
it's okay but you gotta really played a
plane there now her name is bigger than
ever imagine you knew her though and she
didn't offer you the [__] I know now
you're like the [__] me yeah if you
were the odd one out like the situation
she's us yeah we need to be asking all
this dream is asking ninja but does
another five out there who are like at
least five I'm thinking another twenty
at least she was dirty yeah Katarina I'm
on like Caterine oh good for you girl
you get that dick you get that cloak use
these lads all right so when last week's
true news we spoke about I Dobbs and the
controversy he faced after his
girlfriend open it
only funds account well there's been a
development Brian because it really
demonstrates a severe lack of real-world
experience when you're saying that
future jobs are going to be harder to
come by because of an only fans account
like if you think this affects your
standing or your social credibility in
getting jobs you are so sadly mistaken
[Music]
so basically I Nisa got banned from
twitch following everyone finding out
about our only fans do you think this is
fair well fair that she got banned of
twitch yeah it doesn't make sense to me
because there's hundreds of e girls on
twitch and they're doing way worse stuff
a lot of them have only fans account oh
they're trying to make an example out of
other is this cuz it's it's I dog's foot
and girlfriend it doesn't make sense to
me because twitch to me doesn't really
represent itself a sort of a
family-friendly sign it's like YouTube
in a way and there's loads of youtubers
with only fans accounts [__] me there's
porn stars with like [__] YouTube
pages exactly and I'm sure this porn
stars in twitch I'm not saying they're
doing porn on twitch but why would they
ban her account for that it's like a
completely separate thing she was
promoting that only fans oh okay so she
was promoting her only fans on Twitch
and that's the reason they banned oh
okay so that makes a little bit more
sense let's see how bodies they're
[__] [__] I want him to show up in
one of my videos and he's just too
goddamn busy she's got a tits out for a
star but then it's already cleavage not
gonna kill anybody
I don't maybe let the girl cleavage she
sexualizing a dog there maybe there's
other reasons why twitch may abanda
bestiality maybe I mean there's not
wrong with that though is there she's
she's she's in good shape
yeah she is she definitely works out
athletic probably goes for a walk every
day
definitely yeah especially being a dog
for me toast so lockdown is having an
impact on all YouTube friendships right
now you see me and that guy who used to
present true news with this what's his
name
forget it Chuck MIT just split with duty
right now every real name is Jordan I
don't know I don't know and of course
local and Mike two members of impulsive
they've been fighting a little bit
lately I think they've made up now but
you get the point
yeah it's a stressful time and now we've
also got the e boys and I Napa I was
pissed off personally because I thought
it was everyone going to be an uproar
why is true Geordi
involved in the links within the group
but then I never saw my [__] Thunder
in a bird that you could say he's known
for that good old another or as we know
in Ian at NAPA I think so oh no it's
Fraser
whenever I hear the word Fraser baby
I'll hear the Blues our car loons our
salad and scrambled eggs
well anyway nobody seems to give a [__]
that me Steven and Lawrence being
forgotten over the latest group will
threaten created X or 2x - whoa sexual
without the talent yep me Lawrence and
Steven sat on the sidelines now nobody
to stand in his way
Beyonce finally gets to be the lead
singer I say what Will's do and don't
think I don't see what you're doing oh
I'm gonna make [__] content and write
the gravy train and get all the merch
sales I thought of it first
I'm pretty sure it was the Simon that
thought of it first but I was the first
one to say let's do that but less [__]
okay no one's making videos about you
this is do I not look like a needy boy
is that what it is I'm not cute enough
is that what it is I'm a not come enough
[__] reeks I'm gonna take me I'm
gonna take Chuck MIT and a couple of
with us we're gonna start amen amen
coming soon your [__] pricks for
Brian can we stop thinking about you for
a change because I never was apparently
the one that thought of all this is
actually truth
he's been tweeting about it for years
apparently yeah let's see what the
evidence is I don't actually know this
all right so these are some sweets that
I never had posted wanting to do more
collabs with the boys lately so look out
for them me and Alec should be recording
one on his channel tonight this is how I
trick everyone into making a group
channel is happening I promise and it
have been bribery food he kept his
promise I'm sorry it is funny though the
group channel will be made that was
February that's quite close only two
months ago the group travel we will make
it never happened because we couldn't
decide on a name
so which me me less replied no it's
because all of us are useless apparently
people stop being useless and then I
never responded to that saying actually
not true
I wrote up an entire plan and called
multiple meetings about it it's because
you guys are useless that's the mistake
that you've made you've antagonized him
there maybe that's why we'll show you
well show you how well sure useless is
when we make a [__] group without you
act right now this one eh if you could
or Fraser
you send over that plan because maybe I
could put it some use maybe you could
invite an I bet to the II Men no that's
what of he's quite a man material yeah
so be honest he's more of an ad boy kind
of character but if they don't want him
to buy what they're sloppy seconds I
think not technically it's not sloppy
second ever in the boys
so I'm Alex I replied to that sweet
saying we could and should be called the
e boys this was exactly two months ago
the name was given exactly Stanley and
it was we and I'm a bar was inclusive
now I'm not trying to stir things you
never do a thing like that would you
Brian never but you might want to go
back over the last two months phrase
just sit and think have I said anything
that would really irritate these lads
that would make me strongly beat a
slight and not want to be moved into the
group i calling them useless that's a
start he may across the line and I know
we'll easily irritated yeah I was in a
group of them for a year it's like a
gorilla
honestly the lads are going to find out
would you reckon of the new logo yeah
yeah it's cool cuz a lot of people have
the standards of light static 2d logos I
like the 3d element of it it's quite
glossy it's very curvy yes I like it
it's not straight interesting
if it wasn't for I never will any me
miss James Mario I'm not sure if I'd be
tweeting about celebrating Christmas
this year you guys kept me going this
year and I owe you everything from here
on out thanks for looking out for me in
2019 looking forward to next year bro
onwards and upwards
only if you're with me send us a group
channel though when you're out of here
buddy see you layer your mouth there
soon as friend or they can still be his
friend and not be in the group with him
when I was in EXO I didn't go to jut me
and Kyle Frazee sorry lads can talk the
anymore yeah to be free I didn't have to
they've got the idea if you're not in X
or [__] off people are taking this way
too far yeah it's a YouTube group
channel it's almost as if they were
exiled in from the country if anything
if you take it into East ride and you
should use it to power it I mean it's
just being ditched from the best
up-and-coming a group channel in UK you
never see it like this say they're the
Avengers they've come together that sort
of the superheroes maybe I never could
be the super villain it was in kick-ass
the [__] I'm a superhero
henceforth I'll be known as
[__] I've said in this I've
cooking this something out but I'm still
sad that I'm not involved you've created
a group channel about the fifth member
oh I feel bad you know why I feel bad I
mean if it was you people wouldn't feel
as bad because you know you look like
you could take it I never has a face and
this is no disrespect got quite a baby
face so I feel people might feel more
sorry for him because he looks a bit
like the kid from Stuart Little
you know Joe I remember I first see nine
hours videos with alters fact were
youtubers were all kind of outsiders so
he was a little bit of an outsider yeah
and maybe this was his shot at being in
the group inside yeah I mean he was
gonna be a part of the cool guy if you
thought you were tight with these guys
but then you had no idea what they were
doing how tight where you have you
misread that as a friend
have you thought you were closer because
you treated each other a bit we're in a
couple of videos and maybe it wasn't
like how he thought it was and maybe
just the other side the enemies of Alex
and and some of the other lads in the
group are trying to use it to make them
look bad when maybe they should like
we've been having meetings over group
channels since this might be wrong but
like May last year maybe I think at some
point you weren't in the meetings there
was another time where group channel was
being created and I wasn't told about it
so this is the second time so I think
this is another reason why it hurts
apparition have said that if they are
your close friends why would you go on
switch and so about them to everybody
like that if there's other ways of doing
it could you're not going to reach out
because he on Twitter only phoned oh he
knows what he's doing my neighbours not
dumb person he's putting all this into
the public like me maybe thought maybe
he's just in shock
and not thinking straight as well you
know what people are emotional they're
just like [__] as I said earlier they
may have been a message I missed but a
message to me personally think this guy
is army of Lissa message the idea that
there be a good channel and the d-cups
ulema know we sense it I know we sent it
to the wrong account we've got your old
phone number Oh get up being now I'm
ready I want to be in will site shortly
cutoff point yeah sorry
the deadline was last week I'm not
saying I don't want to say anything
there's nothing for me to say possible
there's nothing personal about I'm just
sad you see me says personally what what
the cameras are there's nothing personal
there there's nothing personal there we
need to get believe in Bruce on the
and I've seen before I think there's
definitely more to this story that we
don't know is it just because he's not
marketable you know they want to sell a
lot of t-shirts
would you wear iron Abernethy are we
really gonna split they're 25% in the
20% for a guy who's not selling the
merch anub is not the type of person
that little girls are gonna come okay
sorry you gotta have over big swingin
dicks
we'll then he's got more than that on
his second Channel he's got table on his
second channel what you bring them to
the table for your [__] 20% Jack [__]
sorry sorry I know but I got I went with
it I'm calm I'm calm I didn't mean it I
hope you guys do well the channel I hope
you guys get all the subs in the world
with the idea that I was pushing so much
I hope you succeed and do amazingly well
of it please come on sky [__] age
there's a day I do feel like of us woke
up like ah this is great you know you
talk about the bad guy here's the pose a
Bond villain for you let me list things
which I may have done tweets my
political tweets as terrible some of
them are maybe he's part of the EDL free
Tommy used to eat will was like we don't
want any of that
Tommy [__] in re boys it's hard to not
feel sorry for him but at the same time
I'm very much behind the idea of douche
yourself off get up and show them what a
real I nub is about the man has fallen
down mug shot right he looks like the
Joker it was quite menacing it's the way
that he's heads a little bit back and
he's out looking down just been arrested
for allegedly attacking a woman fair
says I'm going to the shops that's weird
straightaway yeah this guy's been known
to be a bit odd but this is weird if you
read the article I mean it goes on to
say that basically vitality was
allegedly down in Miami hiding in the
bushes
jumped out of the bushes it just started
like beating up this jogger this female
the female said she had no idea who
fight Ali was they found a Fatalis
concent if you seen his concept of no
assume this cut he basically just used
to do pranks now most of these pranks
were really really bad and a lot of them
are fake let's be honest throg videos
for the dross of YouTube except milk but
generally they're bad except now private
Alec nice to meet you
I really never done
for way I just actually stop and talk to
her girl so you look super scared oh my
god this is embarrassing
yeah I'm sorry her reaction was quite
nice if I did that a woman would run
away yeah there's no real setup to the
joke though isn't it it's all just like
are you gonna get your phone number it's
it's not exactly true for yes no my
mom's house
oh she was not playing now he's gone a
lot better I mean like back in the day
can I just say he's going up to
strangers himself and farting on them
Gio says he's gotten a lot better now
because I don't think I need the gold
bucket see the catalog is content used
to be really really [__] what if this is
this is an improvement
Wow he struggled her and repeatedly
punched her in the chest and this is why
youtubers struggle it got taken [__]
seriously by Broncs cuz of dicks like
him on the one hand you've got people
furthering it tried to take us to the
next level ksi trying to break us into
the mainstream and then you've got
Vitaly trying to break some lasses face
it's [__] tonight found another wild
Instagram life for you seeing this can
we show this I don't know we should be
able to show this on YouTube yeah she's
just shoving a vegetable in my mouth it
just feels like we can't ah I don't like
spit does that make your repulse that's
still there yes just really do much for
us to be honest but I know a lot of men
will probably watch on me like what
margin margin especially a green man if
Shrek was watching that if you look good
are there
she looks like quite a good-looking
woman she was that Leona Lewis and she
got a job in the Muppets Kermit
there's a twist scarce getting his dick
sucked a huge update my question is what
happens to your life to the point where
you think I'm gonna go on this guy's
Instagram live feed I'm a soccer
cucumber
what's she gaining from that follow us
because nowadays will do anything for
Instagram followers anything so I came
across this video once where this week
and it was James Charles years ago when
van was around and then if you go on the
thread of the comments there's so many
of our I was a
James Charles he look so different it
looks like make love in you know from
sleep it back to be fair
you've been brushing it in the booty
roll I have his girlfriend uploaded a
video of cutting his hair yeah that's
what a beauty realm I need a haircut is
wearing quarantine all the hairdresser's
are closed I needed a haircut and asked
my girlfriend to do it and she has a
YouTube channel
anakata go subscribe and it's there yeah
and she should come here for me I'm
gonna critique this like I would
critique of any of Gio's at its itself
what the [__] going on with the
lighting we don't like yeah sorry we
don't have thousands of pounds to have
all these lights hundreds of thousands
are all behind the scenes of true news
this is all we shoot we are basically
cinema cameras that we shoot this on
Blackmagic Ursa mini we have all these
lights up here we have great quality
microphones and this we don't have the
budget to do so far this is this is our
flat such a [__] light on then what's
funny just bear that a little picture of
mine but when we say the end result yes
cuz I've seen the end result and can I
just be absolutely clear it's not like
that I was gonna say to be fair it does
say in the title gone wrong question
mark yeah it should be exclamation looks
like she deliberately did that wrong
maybe she did she's like [__] this
haircut I'm gonna get my [__] title
gone wrong whether it [__] killed she
put you and your [__] place head down
shut the [__] up
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right so basically halfway through
the Clippers will use and die in the
Amazon box they had the shave applauded
but we don't have a shave a socket in
our house to show the half job baby or
so but yeah I don't think she did an
awful job all right well I'm wearing a
hat so obviously doesn't want great
right now but I see on this camera look
I think it looks better now after the
hot limited on here I mean all the lumps
and bumps it a little better in real
life than it did on camera but as I say
the shaver died she isn't a hairdresser
got a social [__] the issue is I could
have had one of two things because you
suggested I just got a shaver and just
got all the way over and do this so I
could have had this or this in the
comments a if you would have had this or
B if you would have had this you've
probably got a speech so we'll see more
from Jill's girlfriends YouTube channel
in the future no don't we'll see what
there's a couple a lot of people in the
comments were asking if I had the
channel last week I don't but she has a
channel so go subscribe you won't be
getting one either I'm not having
another you know like condos for the
side memory that's how I made this this
and this
yeah no thank you people all the time
say why don't you make your own channel
I like I already run three true Jordie
TG 2 and the kick off without me those
ships would sink you're right though and
sink so all social distancing on
lockdown would are there are a group of
people who feel the need to make sure
that everyone does it properly by their
rules by the book they're called
quarantine Sheamus one of them was a
doctor and he wasn't happy with a group
of girls in America and well you'll see
just pushed my cars
what's he doing those girls must not be
older than 17 years old and that guy
must be like what he's [__] seven
seas at least 50s doesn't he sixties 56
days and he's pushing those girls around
he was arrested for that we're seeing
more and more examples of this out there
where people are so scared for their
lives that they're going on the attack
they getting aggressive yeah they try to
enforce the rules on everyone you just
can't put your hands on people you just
can't go out and go right you're not to
me as a way from the next person I'm
gonna [__] assault this is nuts one
yes crossing a line down yeah the
world's gone [__] mad innit so
further down in the article it says in
New York an elderly woman died after an
altercation related to social distance
in a
two-year-old pushed eighty six-year-old
Jane Marshall to the ground because she
was standing too close to her that
contradicts the very essence of our
social distancing were meant to be
social distancing to save our people not
kill them if you're feeling the need to
attack someone because they're not
social distancing you're probably mendel
let the police do that you're not the
police go home don't you sell them all
right let other people worry about them
Adele you know that you know Adele she's
getting divorced from this guy right
here
she obviously leveled up throughout the
relationship he didn't just kept Niccolo
up and he's just same she's worth 140
million this might be the first time in
history or one of the first times where
a man has earned jack-shit I think and
the woman's owned a [__] ton and he's
gonna make out like a [__] band-aid
in this divorce yeah we got one back we
got one he seems quite happy about it we
tell it boys one time we did it for the
history books all the richest women in
the world pretty much yeah South Side
Oprah richest [__] because of their
divorces yeah I mean it's historically
consistent in a way because it's always
the one that does the least work that
gets all the money in the end you know
they say we think happened with Jeff
Bezos and his wife and it looks like the
same things happened in here that tells
the one that was you know rolling in the
deep' and doing all the songs this big
bearded slump is gonna take all the
money he's gonna be getting like
apparently like 80 million that's a lot
that's so much is he gonna spend 80
million on probably uh although women I
wonder if our friends over a girl to
find about anything to say about the
coronavirus hold on a minute is that
someone else alleged had a complete
facial reconstruction we are and seeing
each other because we're sisters and
we've already been exposed to each
other's terms what could that mean Bryan
probably just stop do you live next to
each other Gio yeah that's what I was
thinking what's going on that perverted
little mind of yours I don't even think
that they'd be eating each other's
[__] I didn't say that didn't even
think it won't say I'm just so many
people that we know who are struggling
and suffering and losing jobs and out of
school and work and it's something that
we all need to be super careful about
alibi the substitute the word careful
for prayer for we're not mean careful
about this we're being prayerful about
this what the hell does that even mean
recognising at a time like this we need
to support each other and pull together
in ways that I love the father the
sister just goes yeah totally totally I
feel like they're ignoring the elephant
in the room to you this is a channel
about godly girls okay and I got a
question if there's a God why is he
letting thousands of people die cuz it
could you just shut that [__] off could
he quickly hocus pocus a [__] cure
for the rest of us puns yeah I'll be
[__] greatly positive and how can we
stay productive me too so how can we
stay positive one for sure obviously
your you have more time so read your
Bibles I was wondering if a sister I was
into the shares boom well you know read
your Bible yeah my huge struggling to
think that for a second that is like
that
what the [__] do I say yeah deer in the
headlights all she was in was uh uh uh
heart mode and it's all of a sudden she
got a think on her own two feet it's a
Bible for you O Lord are my hope my
trust Oh Lord from my youth and that's
just so encouraging I feel like they've
got it both ways cuz it's like if you're
going through hard times trust God what
happens if you die well then you with
God either way you win slalom what the
[__] is the point meant to me in society
people when they're stressing out when
they're worried when they're scared turn
to something and sometimes whatever that
is it's always gonna be a negative
whether that be alcohol whether that be
drugs whether that be the Bible all of
these things are giving you something to
make you feel better in that moment but
it doesn't necessarily mean that's a
good thing in moderation
everything can be honey I feel like
they're just no better than drug addicts
and yeah that's how addiction started I
feel like this is kind of an addiction
where they're using this thing as a
crutch it's like order the Bible the
Bible the Bible that's got the answer oh
I feel like this Bible I feel like that
Bible to me I hear drug addicts pick the
exact same [__] way and body you're
not seeing a deterioration there but
you're saying sort of lean on something
constantly which is then potentially not
making them address the actual issues
because they're constantly all of the
answers in the Bible maybe the answers
within yourself yeah it prevents them
from thinking rationally as well and it
happens in the world it's like a service
got
so well Willie because the [__]
tenncare people who died in the UK when
[__] being looked after by the looks
of it and so it can be very tempting for
us when we can't change our
circumstances and there's it's out of
our control to just think about the
things that are really hard that are
real but just to think about them so
much that they become this Center focus
of our anxiety and our will and our fear
instead of taking those things to the
Lord in prayer you're hardly until you
go take them things to the Lord what the
[__] are we talking about here she's
totally right some imagery can be
totally - in in our problems and we need
sort of back out and think I need a box
are off for a minute I can't just let it
overtake my mind but then she goes to
take those things to the Lord gonna take
me read problems so the [__] Lord
cannot see goodness cover the red for
the next two [__] months I don't
think so
okay so friend of the show and very good
friend of mine Brodie TV you've had some
cool Brody we've had him on the podcast
you know we've had we featured him in
multiple true news episodes I'll
remember him though yeah you've had some
questions about Brodie sexuality in the
past haven't yet most young guys either
way whatever they're in do you know
about it yeah and Brody just seems to be
wanting irritate people more than
anything yeah it's quite covered about
his interest yeah when it comes to women
however that's changed recently so the
sad man uploaded a video what do they
call it sad man tinder where they
basically have like a girl behind like a
we've all seen the frame yes you
understand the concept it's like tinder
and the guys have to say so there's
another another moment for me they're
just realized I numbers gonna get called
these now the thing where you get left
out yes that's like a definition now
about the I love it oh yeah you've got a
numbered so there was one girl in the
segment in the video who goes by the
name of Lauren Alexis I've seen it where
she seems to be one of those only fun
tab girls all right so this is Lauren
alexis is she your type no I'm not gonna
say oh because this is Brody's crush
okay so we'll just bet okay we can all
add my other female form and say pretty
so we both know Brody very well he's
never really sad any interesting to
girls
now let me be clear I've spent hours and
hours and hours with broaden he's never
ever said anything about a girl
will you know this is the only girl that
he's ever sort of expressed an interest
in really ever so if memory serves
correct the way he chose to let this
girl nor that he was interested in I was
to do this so he did not analyze
streamin it was clipped up and put on
YouTube and then he decided to tweet
that video or she was already following
them yes she was following him because
he tweeted it before so he had a chance
so he chooses to help those chances by
sending her that so this is the tweet
that sent things South Laurel exes I'll
be your Howard Baskin with a picture of
Howard Baskin as a simple I think that's
a really thoughtful way of yeah saying
it it's quite romantic
what was the result of this treatment
followed him on sweater he shot he shot
and she yet we're gonna miss son we've
all been there Brody now's the time to
back away do you think brought she's
unfollowed you you're gonna have to do
miracles to get back from this miracles
oh he's a miracle Lauren like this if
you're watching this follow back Brody
hashtag follow back Brody came together
and this is a thing in a sweet way like
sir he just doesn't know how to express
it we're talking about a [__] we're
talking about a complete idiot a buffoon
and I like him if the man's our clone
right but he does like you I've said it
many times before
the man's a nob but I quite like him
it's all getting a bit the best looking
to brawl you asked us to do this now
it's on you [__] off
alright now I'll do the way if we always
love to and the show's it's the food
review us both of them first up blue van
naturally I want to switch it up the day
I wanna break I want to switch it up but
I nice s go for the food reviewer first
food reviewer I do reviews on the
YouTube
it's a lot and do you know why it
certified and who what's going on that
hot it's beautiful out that's one hell
of American man today we have the
Wachusett the water melone watermelon
beer that might be lovely I think that's
disgusting
we'll find out there are no Westminister
Massachusetts probably one of my top
like like five breweries I love the fact
that it is in the pub having a pint one
day and someone like what's not like you
guys one of my favorite breweries not
even top five all always got a proper
pint glass only a proper man as a proper
pint in the hostel in his bedroom you've
got the water up with the wrong one out
here oh the moment of realization I've
not seen him do that for ages I think he
had a flashback this whole life before
his eyes though it don't smell like
water Malone at all but boom really
kicks in the second you drink it wow
this is a hell of a review if you see
this you gotta get it this is definitely
a buy good water Malone flavor so if
you're at your local [__] thank you for
the people in the comments that cleared
that oh by the way it's a convenience
store you know within America because of
how the practicing's yeah yeah thanks
for that he's not a racist yeah we knew
he's not a racist even though he's
wearing that hat he's not a racist
very good basic review yeah I like it
yeah I've got a five there's not no fat
in there it's straight well yeah right
folks he's back oh he is back Dave a
blue van man he wasn't very well last
week well he's well enough history to
get in front of the camera get in the
right folks and we miss Matt yes we are
we have indeed Dave can help me I wasn't
very well wasn't you I wanted to do this
because people have been so kind asking
about me you can feel the emotions
kanya yeah can you see that yeah Dave
was really on the ropes for this [__]
and at his age he's a big guy you just
worry with your health and that yeah
it's only natural for him to worry a lot
more than the people around that worry
more about him especially with all the
news and that's terrible I honestly
didn't
I didn't know what [__] day wasn't in
there for a day or night June honestly
thought I would die she thought my time
that cool thing you do [__] me Yaron
June's voice there's four been horrible
very emotional for them
god bless quiz on the 27th I'm not
blaming Elliott for it but did you
really have to make do the quiz but I
was cold
I was actually cold torch to me I was
cold
she said I'm a burden no penny when I
went to bed and next thing I know it's
not [__] so can you swear I've got
she was I'm aching all over typical true
Geordie brings everything button himself
had a chat with him went through exactly
how it went that was like he kind of the
same yeah same for me as it wasn't
February [__] this whole freeze and
[__] cold feeling that you've got but
then someone puts a hand in the night
you are so [__] bizarre feeling and
it's hard to breathe
oh man how I feel if my age [__] knows
out there must have felt I woke up on a
Saturday morning and I might as well of
just out Tyson Fury kick [__] out is how
I felt that I feel like Tyson Fury ok
yeah I mentioned the deal I was like
this [__] pay and I had in my ribs
for like a week after I'd stopped
coughing he's a bastard just bite you
and as if you got chunk on at night well
I'm going to see that you're doing
better Dave I mean I think we all are
really mmm just disagree of course we
are we're very [__] delighted that
you all right Dave honestly if anything
that happened I'm out of [__] cried
so I'm glad he's alright Dave is one of
the most kind heart people that we know
so that's what it really hits home for
less you're a foreigner yeah if you said
to me last time who's on the kick off
especially for June you could hear how
much he means to us yes oh thank god
you're all right
and looks like the prayers work after
all maybe yeah maybe the right maybe
those God losses Yeah right it shows I'm
full of [__] so that was another episode
of true news it's been a good one he's
settling into this yeah I mean I got a
lot of nice comments last week thank you
very much to everybody that sentiments
over now is it bad no more airbrushed
any son Gabe no it's who the [__] does
this guy get rid of him we want Lawrence
but no I can't see your comment but I
will find out so well you stuck with geo
for a while
- Lawrence comes back so just embrace
them and embrace me
your Lord and Savior true joy thanks for
watching we'll say is Lina